[Music]
it's this noise and these smiles that
sir david amos loved
as president of this charity for
children and adults with learning
disabilities he championed them and even
took them to the west end
he
make me laugh
he makes me happy
the best ever
and be
his close friend of nearly 25 years says
there was no doubting his commitment
well the david amos that i know
um
was just full of life
um
his full
full strength of character and his big
personality was what marked him out i'd
often pass him a microphone for a speech
at the end of a concert and he'd brush
it to a side and say i don't need that
microphone and he didn't he just
bellowed enthusiasm and passion
and
he was known for it and i think it's
because he truly loved south end
and those here
loved him
even when receiving the honor of a
knighthood this riding school was where
he wanted to celebrate it passionate
about animal welfare sir david was never
a stranger here he was a nightmare
absolute nightmare he would just want to
get in to the horses that you didn't
want him to be in with he'd just go and
pet them on the back side when you
didn't want to pet them on the backside
all over the place absolutely
a nightmare i would say
to be honest
but
love him his ongoing passion though was
to get southend the recognition he
believed it deserved i'm not messing
around mr deputy speaker we've got it
from the prime minister that southend is
going to become a city and it will
become a city
whether in westminster or on the south
coast so-called mr southend was forever
speaking up for local people owners of
these independent shops near his home
say he fought for their businesses when
no one else would south end council
wanted to turn this into bus lanes up
here there's hundreds of shops and he
fought for us
otherwise all these shops up here
employing hundreds of people would have
been closed there was definitely a
sadness you know people were
quite upset
sir david amis died serving the people
his fierce loyalty is a trait they all
respect and many will always remember
ashnahara nags sky news in south end